i have two children one graduated last
year from high school i've got one who's
still in high school so as a parent as a
mom i'm deeply concerned about the
curriculum that's being taught
and i i think really one of the ways to
solve that one of the simplest ways and
president trump has talked about this is
you fund the student not the school
so it puts power back into the hands of
the family gives the family power over
where they want to send their kids and
if if you find out that you're sending
your son and your daughter down to the
local you know the school down the block
and they they're teaching crt and
they're teaching your kids to hate
america and they're teaching your kids
to question their gender you can say no
no no no we're pulling our kids out and
we're going to bring them to this school
and the money follows your child
can you talk about some of the energy
around that because i went to a trump
rally by accident i actually happened to
pass a trump rally in beverly hills
right by rodeo drive pretty woman rodeo
drive in the summer of 2020. i i wasn't
publicly supporting trump at that time i
was kind of going in that direction but
i had never seen it but i go to one of
these rallies he wasn't there it was
just the beverly hills trump rally
and i saw what was the happiest most
joyous
music dancing american flags everywhere
truly diverse in the right sense of
diverse thing i had ever seen before and
that was one of the things that finally
sort of got me over the hump related to
trump you've been in there in the middle
of it with the energy and all that can
you talk about just what that thing is
like it is amazing it is such a
beautiful show of patriotism and love
for america
of course everyone at those events loves
president trump he's the reason they're
there but
you're watching people i was just in
north carolina um at the most recent
trump rally you watch people show up
early it's not easy to get to these
places sometimes they're in out of the
way towns and
they drive a long time to get there they
park a long way back they walk they're
there for hours i'm talking seven eight
nine hours
sometimes it's cold this isn't just a
light level of commitment to president
trump this is a deep deep commitment and
love for a man who put them first who
put working-class americans first who
put our families first
who put our rights first so this is a
deep love and if people think that the
trump movement is gone they've got their
head buried in the sand it is alive and
well and it is growing by the day
i actually get i almost get a little
emotional when i get to these sometimes
because i look out at the sea of
americans who who love america and you
know doesn't matter what color their
skin is doesn't matter what their
religion is doesn't matter where they
came from they might be immigrants they
might have parents who were immigrants
they might be
seventh generation americans
and they're there because the thing that
binds us together
is is that common thread that we love
america and that's why the left and the
radicals on the left are trying to
destroy that and make patriotism
and they're trying to make love for
america a bad thing they're trying to
brainwash our kids into hating america
through the through the perverted
history they're teaching
what you see at a trump rally is just
pure love for this beautiful country
that we have to save it's the most
amazing country in the world
and we can't let it go and i i just love
that i'm watching this movement grow and
that people are waking up
you talk about uh history what would you
do on the education side because
obviously so much of this is related to
education we're watching kids be
either intentionally indoctrinated at
public schools or intentionally
indoctrinated by you know woe
corporations like disney uh what would
you do on the schooling side oh well
we're about to put out our education
plan but i can tell you right now first
of all i signed the hillsdale 1776
pledge that's the kind of education we
should be teaching our kids
not this woke garbage and i have two
children one graduated last year from
high school i've got one who's still in
high school so as a parent as a mom i'm
deeply concerned about the curriculum
that's being taught
and i i think really one of the ways to
solve that one of the simplest ways and
president trump has talked about this is
you fund the student not the school
so it puts power back into the hands of
the family gives the family power over
where they want to send their kids and
if if you find out that you're sending
your son and your daughter down to the
local you know the school down the block
and they they're teaching crt and
they're teaching your kids to hate
america and they're teaching your kids
to question their gender you can say no
no no no we're pulling our kids out and
we're going to bring them to this school
and the money follows your child and
when that happens i will tell you in a
very short order these schools mainly
the government-run schools are gonna
shape up they're gonna realize they're
losing enrollment and they're on the
verge of extinction if they don't shape
up and teach our kids curriculum that
actually makes sense teaches them to be
prepared for the real world it's called
competition right if all of a sudden the
kids are all leaving your school going
to another school
you're going to have to make some
adjustments or you're going to go under
do you think they're too damaged to turn
around so you do that i'm with you on
the the school that you fund students
instead of systems for sure more private
schools more charter schools etc etc do
you think there's any chance even if
they saw a massive drop in enrollment
that
the public schools would have some value
or could come back well if they don't
they'll go the way of the dinosaur
i mean
if pretty soon nobody wants to come to
your school you're it's going to be
pretty hard it's going to be pretty hard
to stick around i'm a big proponent of
homeschooling i think we need to support
our homeschool families they've been
kind of left out of the equation i'm on
the campaign trail i'll tell you what
homeschooling is growing it's growing at
a very rapid clip because people were
tired of having their kids you know
school shut down and then when they went
back to school they had to you know
abuse the children with these masks so
i'm a big proponent of homeschooling i
think we need to support them as well
but we we need to get really serious
about the curriculum my plan calls for
at 10th grade after 10th grade we put
our kids on a track a career track
whether they're going to go to a
four-year college a vocational school
whether they want to get a trade
skills learned and we can have our kids
graduating at age 18 from senior as
senior in high school with a plan for
a job i was just at a school down in
vail
which is down in a tucson area
and they have a welding program they
started at their school
and these kids
are being hired before they even
graduate high school obviously they're
finishing high school but these
companies are coming in offering them 70
to 80 plus
70 to 80 000 or more to take on welding
jobs they're learning that skill in high
school they get full benefits they can
actually raise a family someday with
that kind of a salary we need people in
the trades
really badly and those are the skills
that i think our boys want to do even
our girls want to do those but i look at
sometimes the way we we educate our boys
and i'm a mom to a boy
and i know sometimes he would rather be
in a class where he's learning how to
weld or he's learning
some sort of a trade skill and it his
mind and his hands are being worked
then sitting there listening to a
lecture especially if a teacher's
droning on about crt or or you know
switching genders we got to get our kids
ready for the real world if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell